hello and welcome to this video even
charge yet very strong VM so let's see
what he does against the against the
click miles near the main line his most
strong players do okay I am not really
knowledgeable here he is it seems 94 96
it seems is the idæan okay why not this
is that a problem somehow I don't see
don't see it maybe this is not
strategically desirable
I see hmm pawn takes 96 5625 yeah
and step really that bad
interesting 25 and I take the Queen
check King DNA takes takes and that's a
that's not a good ending okay
I didn't see that this Hanks was
checking I was thinking Knight b6 is
still possible here but not really but
it's that badass attending is that
really that bad
okay take now I'm shaved u5 doesn't do
anything it's that bad maybe it is okay
yeah he does he plays fat moe
I was thinking it doesn't do anything at
six okay check again I will be six check
now ah okay
and then look d1 Marek you have to do it
anyway
yeah well the Alec is my current test
test opening is a bit much to test
against the 2680 player also those
people have their lines prepared the
case on chickie
and pretty rotten yeah I kind of knew
that I'll be five should not work but
okay if you don't quite know how why
yeah oh yeah checkmate
okay that was cute so I cannot and play
b5 down now I have to play I can Knight
b6 or something okay hazard second it's
good to know I mean I'm learning
learning by doing him and here you don't
have a playable playable position flower
lawn castles nope that's not what you
want to do yeah I can check check check
King bagi okay that's a completely
terrible position okay Wyatt so um
ultimately you have to do this that
looks really solid really me nothing
great that looks solid I will get to
drape this very likely I don't see a
good way to put it also and that just
that that should just be a slight edge
white okay guys thanks for watching